buddy hello hello i am here to lower my average for the the
stream data thing about how long does it take for a vtuber
to start their stream and then start streaming i'm here to
lower the average right now i this is a competitive now now
it's competitive they spoke my link i saw that now it's
serious i got get up on the leader point
but will you lower it?
Well the yam time is like it depends like today it's like it
depends on what's going on in my life.
Yeah like the competitive late average stat.
I gotta lower my KD.
I mean I gotta I gotta up my KD or lower it.
I don't know.
I think that's lowering the KD at that point.
It would be okay.
I gotta lower my l okay l y guys i gotta lower my l y it's
important my l y average
all right um other than that nothing really important uh
yeah we're not trying to lower that increase the yapp time
though alan thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
i don't think i can make it it really depends on like what's
going on really have a lot to yapp right now other than the
fact uh i just found out that spongebop is incredibly
popular in china specifically i i think it's just because
like uh i think like i don't know maybe like two or three
years ago spongebop recently got not recently two to three
years ago uh spongebop got finally got like um adapted in
the chinese medium so there's so much merch coming It's like
My Little Pony.
There's a lot of merch coming from China for Chinese
SpongeBob exclusives.
And I...
I don't know, guys.
I actually own, like, you know, like, there's, like, blind
boxes, too.
So it's, like, Tom and Jerry.
We're, like, after a couple, like, you know, Tom and Jerry
was super popular in China.
Like, it still is.
But around, like, 2000s, Tom and Jerry surfaced into...
um surface like like like made its way to china and
everybody in china watched tom and jerry um back in the day
and now it's sponge bob's turn um surprisingly i did i
remember when i was in china i saw the chinese dub of sponge
bob and it's like really accurate like they actually got
voice actors that saw sound like got a voice actor that
sounded like tom kenny but what if tom kenny was I'm not
joking.
I'm not joking.
Wait, let me see if I can find Chinese SpongeBob.
It sounded like Chinese Tom Kenny.
I swear to God.
Okay, let's see how you can find it.
What was six years ago?
Let's see if I can find it.
Okay, wait, okay.
Maybe it's the more recent one.
Let's look at the recent one.
oh there it is there it okay now now that sound is more like
chinese tom kenny i i the earlier okay the early ones was
like not not it but then the most recent episodes it does it
sounds like him like the first the first time okay i'll show
you guys like when they first tried to dub sponge bob And I
was like, yeah, never mind.
Wait, I want to know if this is, let me double check,
though, for sure.
Let me, all right.
All right, let me double check, though.
Let me find it.
Also, let me see, okay.
I need, like, a recent year.
A recent year, because, okay.
Learn Chinese with TV shows.
Chinese with SpongeBob.
Is this...
It's like an actual...
Let's learn Chinese with SpongeBob.
I'm gatekeeping.
Here's Chinese Patrick, though.
I'll give you...
Wait, that sounds like...
Wait, it does sound like Patrick if he was Chinese.
Alright, here's...
It's Chinese, Patrick, though.
Oh, my God, it sounds just like him.
It's Mandarin.
No way.
Oh, the hard part right now is just trying to find the one
that's dubbed in China.
Because there's other Chinese dubs of SpongeBob from
different regions.
But I'm trying to find the one that's in China.
for China.
I know it's not bad, right?
That's Patrick if you learn Chinese.
Do you guys think people tell her to play Uma Musabe?
So she downloaded a horse game.
Oh, it's thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Put them in Dynasty Warriors.
Patricia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's like that.
You know what?
It's not, this is not AI by the way, but it reminded me of
when Charlie, found a, um, a channel that does like dubs of
him speaking Chinese on his, on his YouTube videos.
It just reminded me of that because it, like, it's like,
what if Charlie speaks Chinese?
What if Boy is critical?
Somehow just woke up and learned how to speak Chinese.
It just reminded me of that.
It's like, it's so uncanny.
It was like, oh my God, it literally sounds exactly like the
English Patrick voice actor.
But what if he just speaks, spoke Chinese?
That's so cool.
I was just like, oh my god, that's actually crazy.
That's actually crazy cool.
They casted perfectly.
Anyway, sorry, off topic.
If you guys want to, I'm trying to find like the SpongeBob
one where it literally just sounded like Tom Kenny.
But what if he just spoke Chinese?
I'm trying to find that right now, but I'm having a hard
time because like, There is a dub of it, but it's not the
one where he sounded just like Tom Kenny.
So, that's the main issue, right?
I'm trying to find the one where he sounds like Tom Kenny.
I'm trying so hard to find it.
This is this.
Oh, no, it was definitely not that.
It was definitely not that.
is this one
oh my god there's that
oh my god there's the Chinese pirate it sounds just like
they made I didn't even realize sorry they did the dub of
the intro too and I didn't realize wait that sounds so
accurate it sounds just like him too alright I'm in like a
guys I'm in like a little
I'm in a rabbit hole right now Chinese SpongeBob
I'm holy shit it does my algorithm is just gonna be like
SpongeBob intros but what if they're in Chinese there's
SpongeBob rabbit hole oh my god okay okay this is
wait wait look at the top this is Chinese Sandy, but somehow
the Chinese is in a Texas accent.
How does she do that?
Oh my god.
That's actually so impressive.
Not gonna lie.
That's really impressive.
I've been doing the Chinese SpongeBob algorithm.
Ni hao-di, y'all.
oh my god it sounds like it does though it sounds like it's
chinese sandy but like he she put a accent a texas accent oh
my god accurate it's actually nihility i'm seeing it live
all right anyway so okay i want to talk about this because
instead of merch that comes out of um the fact that like um
it's really popular right now in uh in china and i saw this
merch so there's a lot of merch you can get right now of
sponge bob like it's like the golden age of sponge bob merch
right now uh and this was one of them this is official merch
uh official sponge bob merch uh from china um of squidward
and you're like oh it be the you really want to show it's
because it's like handsome squidward right well no it's i'll
show you the box first and then i'll show you the box for
you guys all right so
oh you see the background a lot of sponge about merch too so
This is a box and you're like, okay, okay, it's not that
bad.
So it's a phone holder.
For those who are wondering, what is that?
This is a phone holder where you can put the phone on
Squidward's cheeks.
But this was, so you're just like, okay, that is not that
bad.
It's like a little, huh?
It's a little, huh, but then you take it out of the box in a
specific angle.
If you look at it at a specific angle, it looks like he's
sort of giving you bedroom eyes while he's holding up your
phone.
Oh, yeah, a very specific angle.
why is he looking at me like like it's not as bad if you
look at it in the box way like like your but then when you
when you tilted a little bit to the left uh why is he giving
me those eyes fun ball thank you for super chat thank you
thank you where's the dokey bird version that comes from a
broken toilet patro so think of a super chat thank you thank
you so dokey How many do you own?
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you.
Welcome back, Doki.
I hope you had a nice vacation.
I did.
I had a great vacation.
Now I'm showing you guys bedroom-ass Squidward.
Why is Squidward throwing it back?
So that's some of the merch.
Also, my Twitter algorithm at one point was just all
SpongeBob merch.
Also, there's, because I clicked on, I clicked on
specifically, I clicked on that link for that picture, and
then my Twitter algorithm was for, like, I think, like, five
minutes just SpongeBob merch, not just specifically
SpongeBob merch, but SpongeBob merch from China.
So there was a lot of very interesting merch I saw after
that.
I think there was like Squidward blind boxes where the
secret was, you can legitimately get handsome Squidward.
So let me show you guys this.
You can get a handsome Squidward.
It's the secret though.
It's a blind box of all of Squidward plushies and one of
them.
of them was handsome squidward so i think like but it's like
one out of like a million like not million that's me fucking
uh that's me just inflating numbers but like i think it
really cute because this is the normal one this is like the
normal ones you can get like like squidward you know and oh
my god with the blind box this is house wait that's so cute
wait okay wait a minute Wait a minute, Squidward.
Blind box, plush.
Wait, that's so cute.
Wait a minute.
That's actually so fucking cute.
Wait, the blind box is his house.
I'm not gonna buy any of them.
I'm just saying.
I'm just looking, guys.
I'm just, guys, I'm just looking.
Don't keep, no.
Wait, this is so cute.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, guys, this is actually so cute.
Wait a minute.
I'm not buying any.
I'm just, I'm just, I'm browsing.
I'm just, I'm browsing, guys.
But, oh my God, wait, this is actually fucking adorable.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait, look at this.
Look at, wait, look.
Oh my, wait, they can stand up on their own.
Wait, the tentacles are opposable.
just i'm just guys guys i'm just window shopping guys i'm
just window shopping oh my god wait the tentacles and and
the legs are posable you can move you can move them why is
he naked there wait there's a naked squid oh no she's going
for a debit card silent stopper simple minor thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you don't keep swindling
blind box one i think it's super chat thank you thank you go
to the super chat thank you thank you i was that from that
episode where mr crab's daughter was preparing for his 16th
birthday new super chat thank you thank you oh my okay i
think that's real guys okay okay i'm just appreciating the
fine arts right now guys i'm okay but what if i buy one box
just just just one box guys just i'm just appreciating fine
arts okay i like how detailed and i have zero trust in you
making sound financial decisions right now even the super
chat thank you thank you anyway so other than that also did
you guys see the uh uh let's see do you guys see the
one-piece sponge bob collab that they're doing i don't know
if that it's it's that gonna release in america i i don't
it's such a weird combination the what yeah so mcdonald's um
is doing a special collab um that's one piece in sponge bob
which i'm pretty sure scalper's gonna have
so so yeah so yeah so sponge bob is loofy um i i don't know
it's so interesting i i don't know where this combination
came from at all um but it's like like i god's i know
there's godzilla and halakitti also for a collab but like i
felt like that in some way makes sense because halakitti
does collabs of everything uh she's like a little bicycle
She does collabs of everything.
But like, I guess because it's the ocean, I guess.
Yeah, I think the correlation is, yeah, it's official.
It is.
It is official.
So like, I don't know.
I feel like Scalper is going to have such a great time with
this collab.
I don't know if any kids are going to be just seeing any of
this.
I don't know if any of the children.
getting their happy meals anytime soon guys uh but anyway
let me show you guys yeah so these are the toys that's
coming in with the uh with with the sponge bob what i like
how patrick zorro i believe sandy is nami and then sponge
wow sponge bob you get two you get two toys in your happy
meal uh i like that squidward side G, Gary's Choppa, and
then the rest.
Okay, Pearl as Robin, SpongeBob as, what is it called?
You can tell I don't watch one.
The Gear 5, yeah, Gear 5 SpongeBob.
Yeah, Larry's Frankie.
I thought it was so interesting.
They just announced this, I think, yesterday.
Interesting choice.
I was very surprised because I was like, it just feels like
it came out of nowhere.
You know, they're like, all right, what do kids like?
SpongeBob.
All right, what do?
What do kids also like?
One piece.
Oh, but what if we put both of those together?
Got to get them young.
Got to get them into One Piece young, you know?
Like,
It's genius.
Oh my God.
Promote that man.
Give him a fucking, give him his own office.
He knows what he, he knows what, he knows capitalism.
Guys, get those kids young to watch the thousand plus
episodes because by the time they finish it, they'll be
teenagers.
So they got started, they got started off young.
Yeah, make that Matt CEO right now.
So yeah, anyway, just want to let you guys know about this
is like SpongeBob news.
Today's theme of a life update, SpongeBob.
Hey, make sure you guys are up to date with the SpongeBob
lore, guys.
I know, don't want, don't, you don't need to thank me,
everybody.
Just, yeah, I'm just doing, just doing God's work.
That's today's SpongeBob update.
all right anyway we're going to be playing a game called oh
wait how do i how do i full screen shit again well how to
full screen uh shortcut oh
my all right let's see uh
alt enter okay alt oh is it alt enter
Okay, what is it?
Window, turns, web...
Okay, I need, like, game.
I need games.
Is it Alt-Enter?
It's not working.
All right, I guess we're going to have a tiny, tiny screen.
All right, horse magnifier.
This is as big as it can get.
All right, here we go.
All right, hello, and thank you for purchasing horse
magnifier.
magnifier the full horse now you guys might be wondering why
did I buy a horse magnifier the full horse well you see I
saw it on my I saw it as a on my popular upcoming and I saw
it again at popular new release so I was like oh that must
be a really good game and I read the description and it says
this is a game about magnifying horses and I saw the reviews
and it was like
So I was like, man, this game about horses must be a really
good game about horses.
And I read this review or said, generally thought that
gaming was dead until this masterpiece dropped.
Truly a game that we lowly peasants do not deserve to have.
And I saw this other review as a possible horse enjoyer.
This game was one of beauty and grace.
to my eyes and at time a chuckle to my bones horses do have
souls and love being magnified so I was like man this must
be a really good game this must be a really good game about
horses
this could be game of the year
so so I was just like you know what I got give this a try I
got I gotta see what these guys are smoking.
Maybe horses.
They ain't horsing around.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, so anyway.
Hello and thank you for purchasing Horse Magnifier, the full
horse.
This is not a horror game.
It is... Oh, thank God.
Thank God for this disclaimer.
It's good to know.
Despite this, there are jumpscares.
Do you want to keep the... You know what?
Surprise me with those horses.
I like to be... I want to be jumped scared by a horse.
Okay, yeah, that was the only, okay.
That was the only jump.
Wow, you know what?
Giving that plus one.
That was a good horse.
That was the only jump scare in the game.
Thanks.
I think that was a good horse, guys.
Oh my god, that's a good horse.
All right, sound, guys.
Let me know if it's horsing enough.
All right, settings.
Okay, there you go.
screen there we go okay not to fix this a little too big now
all right full screen reduce background motion colorblind
okay now one jump scare all right horsey worlds how many
people worked on this a short game but made with g dot
engine oh that's a good sign these horses are getting kind
of hungry Goodness, these horses are intangible.
The horse from horse magnifier.
Every other horse stock.
I'm so green.
Special thanks.
All right, nice.
Horses, the entire species.
Shout out to my boy horses, guys.
Every single one of them.
All right, let's look at this.
All right, this is a cat.
game about magnifying horses.
Drag the lenses to correct position.
I think it's like this.
Yeah.
Okay.
Maybe like that.
Oh!
I'm so good at magnifying horses, guys.
Oh my god.
Game of the year.
Oh shit.
I got to okay.
Oh, that's a big dog.
for a horse all right well it's that and then maybe like
this yeah or in a big ass nose like that no what else could
it be i know my magnifying glass there's no way oh it's like
there we go wait it's like that if that's one to one oh
maybe oh it's because the dumpy is bigger, right?
It's practically what?
How much more can I magnify?
It's gotta be almost precise.
Oh no, it's actually a lot harder now.
Look at it!
Oh, wait.
Maybe like this.
There's no way.
How much more can I do it?
How much more can I do?
do this.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my God.
Three pixels.
That's practically.
Oh, okay.
All right.
What the fuck is this?
How?
Oh, is this extra?
Is this enhanced?
Oh, you enhanced the enhanced?
Oh, my God.
Are we allowed to do that?
Is this legal?
Is this...
We're doing something no horse should be exposed to.
Is this even legal, guys?
Okay.
There we go.
That's next level.
Enhancing the enhancement.
Okay, you're doing important work here.
I know.
I know I am.
Okay, tiny head.
Tiny horse head.
Okay, maybe a tiny horse head.
Big ass chest.
Whoa!
First try!
It's CSI cat, so can I, too.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck happened to this horse?
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, chest skinny legs what the fuck do i do here it must be
okay wait wait all right i don't like how this horse look i
think he has a wonderful personality what the fuck do i do
here oh this is weird this is a weird horse
this is a weird this is a weird what do i do This horse, my,
this horse is fucking weird.
I, what can I even do with this horse?
He's so weird.
Okay, obviously I do that.
And then maybe, oh no, I don't know.
I don't know.
How do I, this horse not looking right.
Maybe like this.
and then I do like
that okay it sort of looks like him what
about the legs oh there you go I made an abomination five
pixels god I'm a master if you ever need a horse magnified
you know who to call you know who to call guys Oh shit, this
looks like my little pony now.
A bunny horse.
How the fuck do I do that?
Oh.
Okay, and then we enhance the enhancement.
No, that doesn't look right.
Okay, I'm...
Alright.
I'll say, yo, top five.
I say this top three games about magnifying horses.
Okay.
how the fuck okay what do i do all right obviously it's
right here oh and now put this
maybe no what holy shit
okay it stops okay i know it stops here but what else do i
do oh maybe like yeah okay the game had to help me there oh
my god that's a sick ass horse holy shit did you guys catch
that like did you guys see that oh my god that horse did a
fucking backflip there finally a game for us i know finally
this is what the people wanted a game that i've been
yearning for for so long finally is here okay now i don't
know now now i'm confused that's a holy shit that's a big
ass stomach maybe like where do i put this is there cheat
sheet can i get a hint like maybe here and then no because
then it drags drags it so it should be like here oh my god i
don't know i actually i don't know i i don't know i be like
this oh there it is There it is.
Yeah, that horse is fucking pregnant.
All right, next level.
Where am I at?
You can hold shift or compare your horses with the goal.
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's helpful, actually.
All right, now, oh, now we're horsing around.
Now we're actually horsing around.
Oh, my God.
All right, this is...
Oh, okay, obviously it's like that.
Yeah, there we go.
We bring the nose up a little bit.
And then, okay, how do I make the ears bigger, though?
Okay, this is obviously the eyes.
Okay, it's a bit too much, though, is it?
Do you guys think that's a little too much there on the
eyes?
Just a little bit?
Oh, maybe if I enhance, nope, nope, not enhancing.
Okay, maybe if I, oh, I get, I see.
Oh, I see, I see now.
I see the vision.
right now I see it in my head I I see where the horse is
coming from oh shit how do I do this it's like that right
okay well I got to figure out how to get the hair right
though the hair is the issue oh there we go never mind it's
not bigger than the issue as i thought i was nice next level
please all right the humble mosquito okay that's like the
enhancement of enhanced so i remember i know that now they
figure out how oh god those hips okay we gotta figure out
how to how okay honestly how many oh i do have hints okay
how what okay yeah my horse went on ozempic uh how did you
know and she got and he got like Like the hip adjustment
surgery.
Yeah.
Yeah, he did.
My horse is beautiful.
Do not judge my horse.
You're just jealous.
You wish your horse was as fabulous as my horse.
It was a choice.
Wait, actually, how did I do this?
I enhanced it, but I still have that.
Is that not how I enhance?
Wait a minute.
Oh, I forgot about that nose.
Oh, how do I pull this further?
Is that as far as it could go, Captain?
Oh, this is as far as it can go.
Yeah, my horse is on Ozempic.
What's your horse on?
Yeah.
And he got hip adjustment.
He got like, he got, he got his hip snatched.
I know you're so jealous.
What is horse?
I, you know, I, you know, yeah, that seems right.
Yeah.
all right next level horsey tip sometimes horses melt in the
process called horse melting all right how do I whoa make
that horse melt oh my god okay wait hold how the fuck oh
like that bro how do I get it maybe oh okay okay all right
but How do I get it to be more circular?
Wait, how do I do...
Oh, this is hard.
Oh, this is getting a little difficult, guys.
How do I make it melt like that, though?
Okay.
Obviously, the legs are like this, because it's like long,
you know?
But like...
How do I do that?
I got legs part correct right yeah this part is correct but
how do I oh my gosh that's a hunchback of Notre Dame how did
he do that
maybe like this oh oh there you go there we go my horse got
a tumor don't worry the doctor said it's benign do not worry
guys the tumor is benign it'll be fine yeah look at that
horse go you can tell he's having great time with benign
tumor i should have drank that one billion day blind i
shouldn't drink that one billion day blinding stew okay
obviously it's like this right i mean it's so obvious or
maybe it's like this
Maybe it's double in hat.
Oh shit, it's not double in hats.
How do I blind my horse in game?
In game!
There we go, I blinded him.
Yeah, who's a good horse?
Yeah!
Yippicay, yay!
Alright.
What's this?
Oh, it's this.
God, I'm so...
Oh, my God.
I'm actually, like, the horse magnifier.
I caught that instantly.
Oh, shit!
There's a...
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, he's fine.
Oh, oh.
He's okay.
Guys, don't worry.
Don't keep...
look he's fine see he's fine you can still hear him he's
fine oh they had one horse guys there was always only one
horse it was always one horse Guys,
no other horses existed.
Like that?
What the fuck am I supposed to do with this?
Oh, this is hard.
Good.
I mean, it's practically there.
What do you want me to do?
he's inside oh the feet i had two left feet whoops
oh my god his fucking back i didn't even notice his goddamn
oh my how the fuck okay
okay we this we can we can do this oh my god how do i rotate
one's back back to where it belongs I okay all right um got
that sorted what
what okay it's
practically a horse that's
practically a horse what more does he want from me oh okay
okay wait
Oh, there we go.
It's practically a horse.
See, look at that.
A horse is a horse.
Oh, now we're back to our regular horsey duties.
Alright.
If it ain't broke, guys.
If it ain't broke.
Where the fuck does this go?
Like that?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my gosh.
If you ever need your horse magnifying, I'm your girl.
all right horsey tip if multiple magnifiers stack make sure
one is correct before putting more on top okay well it's
obviously this and then oh this fucks with me though oh this
It's very fucky-wucky right now.
It's like...
There we go.
That's easy.
That one's easy.
I mean, I just have to be mirrored when I don't... Oh, not
this guy again.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
This guy.
Alright.
And this... And... Oh, okay.
Okay.
Obviously, it's the nose.
The nose is part of this.
I can tell.
Is it the eyes?
Okay, the eyes.
are also inverted and then there we go nice magnified that's
right magnified 10 out of 10 more magnifiers yeah oh shit
the guy someone bit his ass off okay no this is okay all
right all right this is gonna all right guys All right, now
we're playing with magnets.
Now we're playing with magnifying glasses.
Okay, guys.
Oh, we're getting extra freaky here.
What?
How?
Oh, this is...
Oh, no.
Okay, I assume it's like that.
And then what the fuck do I do with this?
I'm gonna bite this horse ass off.
Number one.
All right, and then I gotta figure out what to do here.
How the fuck?
All right, this is a very hungry horse.
Okay, now I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
Oh, this is hard.
here then where the fuck do I put this change the order okay
oh maybe it's like right here bite the ass right here I
don't think the order matters though Oh, this is hard.
I'm locked in.
That's the expert horse magnifier.
I got a job to do.
They paid good money to get their horses magnified, guys.
I ain't gonna half-ass this.
They paid millions of dollars to get their horses magnified.
What?
Okay, it's like this.
Oh my god, I did it.
I don't know what I did.
I did it.
I'm so good.
I'm just a natural.
I did it.
I don't know what I did, but I did it.
Locate the apple.
What?
Oh, my God.
We're magnifying things we've never magnified before.
Oh, I got a...
Guys, I got a promotion.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it has to be, like, in his stomach, right?
Where would...
Okay, there's another horse in there.
There's a banana.
There's a burger.
There's a dump truck there.
Where would you put an apple?
Oh, there it is.
In your hoof.
Of course, that's where you put it.
Where else would you put it?
I wonder if these horses like being magnified.
I think he's having a great time.
We got straightened out his...
Okay, first off, we got straightened out his back right
here.
And then...
Oh, and then...
Like that.
There we go.
I think he's happy.
Look at that.
That horse is happy.
That's a happy horse right there.
He's like, fuck yeah.
Magnify me harder, girl.
Maybe it feels like a good stretch.
Okay, now I don't know.
This one's a little...
Ooh, this one's a little complicated.
I assume it's like that.
And then...
Then what do I do here?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's a good horse.
Okay, but what the fuck am I supposed to do?
Oh, there we go.
We got it.
That also a good horse?
Not.
it has to be this
maybe I mean I guess
oh this is hard how do I stretch the eyes though
is it inverse okay now I'm confused oh there we go okay
that's how I stretch it alright
oh don't worry don't worry this doesn't and hurt the horse,
guys.
Oh, there we go.
Magnifique.
Oh, four pixels.
Yeah.
Then again, they're not actually being stretches.
Yeah, guys.
They're not actually...
This is humane.
Very humane.
Oh, that's a lot.
That's like those, like, what are those...
Sorry, what are those dogs?
Sorry.
What are those animals that are not horses called again?
You know, they're like horses, but they're smaller-sized
horses.
And, like, instead of saying nay, they say wolf.
I can't remember.
It's like, they're all horse-shaped to me.
Oh, yeah.
The boar-boar-zoi horse.
Yeah, yeah.
I was thinking about boarzoor.
Boarzoi.
Oh, look at me.
I'm a cyclop.
Alright, this one's hard.
What the fuck is wrong with this horse?
Oh, there...
Oh, okay.
Obviously.
Okay, okay.
It's like here.
Maybe not as obvious as I would like.
Where the fuck do I put this?
Oh.
There we go.
Okay.
It's the Cyclops.
He just has a headache.
Alright, next level.
What the fuck?
Alright, I need to know how, guys.
Okay, I'm gonna check how many horses are there.
Oh, that's a lot of.
I've magnified 24 horses.
Oh my god, I'm halfway there.
It's only, oh my god.
I've magnified half.
Guys, look at that.
That's a big horse, guys.
That's a fucking big horse.
at the end.
Guys, guys, I think we might be ending with a horse.
I'm not sure yet, though.
I'm not sure yet, but there's a possibility that we're
ending this game with a horse.
It's just a little hypothesis, you know?
I'm not, I'm not like 100% sure yet.
but it could be a horse all right next horse oh man these
horses are getting oh these what
oh we're going places no horse should go how the fuck oh
there we go that's die that looks like a God, a biblically
accurate horse.
Got me again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
El Trick horse.
Where do they get all these horses from?
Oh.
Okay.
We gotta give him a little happy cheek.
Nope.
There we go.
Look at that.
He's so happy.
Puffing out his cheeks.
Can I request a long-legged donkey for this long face?
Okay.
Don't even have that on right now.
Oh, I'm cut off.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck is that?
All right, guys.
I gotta figure this horse out real quick.
All right.
Obviously, it's a cut right here.
And then...
Oh!
yeah here we go almost the same what the fuck is it I'm
magnifying guys guys read the title I'm doing what the title
is telling me to do guys it's how do you not understand I'm
magnifying horses it's literally exactly what I'm supposed
to do I'm magnifying horses I'm all right this now I'm
confused now now I'm confused with my job like what is what
what's my job now like
what where does the horse begin and where does the horse
stop wait what now
I don't even know
I don't know Oh, this is hard
I see it I don't What do you see With your horse eyes
Oh, you just gotta feel Guys, I need Guys, I might need my
first hit I I might need to consult the horse council About
this This might be something the horse council must assist
me in.
Like, but how do I pull it?
Like, where do I put this?
Okay, maybe like...
And then I pull this.
Oh, oh, oh, I see it!
I see it!
Spend more than three minutes on a sandalope.
This is hard!
We mean standard level.
I see.
I see the horse.
The horse sees me.
I'm thinking going crazy.
I see horses.
It's like I see dead people.
Oh my god.
Did not have to consult the horse cons council.
I told you.
Oh my god, what?
Oh no, now...
What?
How do I make him green?
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, that's the goal.
Oh, shit.
Now we're thinking of colors.
Okay.
There we go.
But so green.
He's so green.
That's a green horse.
Oh my god.
They're getting so hard.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh.
I assume it's like this first.
What?
I mean, an enhanced?
No.
No?
Yes?
No.
What's with the long face?
Are you happy to see?
Oh, what?
Okay.
Maybe?
I'm going to pee.
I can't.
I'll be right back.
Every time I close my eyes, I see a horse.
Magnifier.
I'm magnifying horses right now in my head.
J, a tub, J, Juke, Cyber, Nixie, Krish, Affiliate, Bite,
Anya, Solid, Medi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Where do I?
Where do I put you?
Where do these horses go?
Unless...
Okay, obviously, that's like that.
Then what do I do?
Where do you go after...
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
That's where you go.
Yeah, there you go.
I definitely knew.
That's an expert horse magnifier.
What the fuck?
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
Whoa, that's a bird.
Uh, I guess?
Okay.
And what do I do after that?
I have to be close.
I have to be close to cracking it.
What do they mean?
It's right here!
My god, it's right here.
It's right here somewhere.
I've cracked it!
It's literally the same.
Except for the eyes.
It's literally...
It's literally the same thing.
Oh, there we go.
we go.
There we go.
How accurate.
Okay, yeah, that's not as accurate.
Check up my long mode.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, shit.
All right.
Well, I'm checking it out now.
It's like right here.
And then we got a reverse.
There we go.
Oh, that one was easy.
Oh, my God.
What shit they put me through in the last round?
That one.
Oh my God.
Oh, I'm still so green.
What the fuck?
What the?
What?
What am I looking at?
I have to think what color is it?
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm calm.
Okay.
What the fuck?
What the fuck
is...
Okay, there we go.
He's so green.
It's just a normal colored horse, guys.
He's still so...
Oh, oh, don't someone please shoot a nail gun through him.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's an abomination to horse cats.
Oh my god.
You should not be alive.
You take that back, Toki.
He's beautiful.
Oh my god.
You are a horse that should not exist.
No, he's a cute horse.
It's like that.
means I do this.
It's a horse that no mother can love.
How?
I guess?
I... What?
What?
I don't know.
What am I doing?
What am I doing my life anymore?
What has my life become?
What?
little dokey in 20 years you're gonna be magnifying horses
you're gonna start magnifying oh man wonder what future
dokey is gonna get us a job oh little dokey you're gonna
start magnifying horses later
whoa yeah way This is my life now.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm back with my horses.
Whoa.
Do very.
All my education has led me to this moment.
Horse.
Oh my god.
What did I do with you?
Oh.
What the fuck do I do with you?
Let your fucking ballsack chin.
Guys, I might need to call SOS.
I might need to call SOS on this fucking horse.
I don't know what to do!
That's it, that's it.
Two out of four.
Though it looks like this magnify is two left.
Which one?
This one?
Two left and two above?
Oh.
All right, I made the ball, Chin.
All right, what's this?
You're halfway through.
This is halfway.
This, I've already had an identity card.
crisis and I'm only halfway.
How many, how many more how many more horses can there be?
There's no way.
There's more horses.
There's actually more horses to go.
Now a very good time for the mind break, guys.
There is actually more horses.
I don't know how to put this.
What?
Okay, I know it cuts there, but like, what do I do?
What do I do with this information?
What?
Oh, it's getting so hard now.
Got the squares right?
What
more can I do with the squares, though?
Okay, I know I have to cut this guy's hair.
I don't know.
I, I don't know.
I don't.
I, oh, I, I don't know.
Everything I know about horses.
None of them are correct!
There's no way none of them are correct.
There's no way.
There's, there's no way.
There's no, not, not!
How is that possible?
None of them?
okay that has to be close right
oh my god I'm practically there I'm cooking right now there
we go from none to there yes now I'm thinking of horses from
none to what I had oh my god now what am I doing
what okay okay give me a sec
I what
what do I do with this
I don't know I'm so tired
I'm so tired
That's a real thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't.
You got two of us.
What are the two?
I'm talking.
Why do you have so many magnifying glass?
Why?
I- Whoa!
Please help!
Help!
Okay, stop horse around, get back to train, we need to win
the der- Oh wait, wrong game.
Super, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Help me!
What is he circling?
Which one?
This one?
Looks like this one's too right.
Which one is that?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Okay, alright, the colors are not as bad.
Now that I've dealt, now that I've dealt with all of them,
the colors are not as bad as the other ones I'm doing.
Okay, now he's purple.
But what if, what, okay, what if he's blue?
This is a circle that solves everything.
There we go.
I'm so green.
He's still so green.
Feed me, I'm so hungry.
Green?
Green.
Yay!
Wait, what happens if I feed him a grenade?
Oh, he's fine.
Oh.
Hello, spider.
You're so green.
Oh, there we go.
No!
Not again.
What if he came a black horse?
Guys.
What?
Oh, now we're thinking.
Oh, I get it.
Now we're thinking.
portal I see what you did there I'm just like biting his own
ass
not is this not it okay there we go yeah what you got now
he's thinking with portals oh my god oh no All right.
That's not it?
There we go.
Easy.
Oh, we're on the portal.
We're on the portal level.
Oh, back to magnify.
It's gonna get weird.
This is where it gets weird.
This is a don't worry.
This is where it's gonna get weird now.
Now we're the weird part.
Oh god.
Oh god, this is where it's gonna get weird.
This is where it's gonna get weird guys.
What am I?
What?
Oh, what is going on?
I don't I don't know anymore.
I
Okay.
All right.
I...
Oh.
Okay.
You got two out of four.
This looks like this horsey's way...
Which one?
Which?
Which...
Which one?
This one?
Okay, there we go.
Here we go.
It's this one.
It's these circles.
All the magnifying glass.
How would I know?
It was all of them.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
All right, now we're syncing with portals.
Now, now we're syncing with portals.
Now we're syncing with portals.
Now we're syncing it with portals, right?
Now, we're thinking with portals right now right now we're
thinking with portals right now right here right here right
right now we are thinking right here and now we are We're
thinking with portals.
Right here?
Right now.
We're thinking with portals.
Right here?
Right?
Now!
Right here?
Right now.
How, how much more?
How much?
Stop.
How much more?
Okay.
Two left and a teensy bit two above.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
Now we're thinking of portals.
I don't even care that I'm using his.
Guys, like, what?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, we're so close.
We're so close.
We're...
I can't...
We're right there.
The big horse in the sky.
It's right there.
I can't.
I both.
I'm almost there.
Now we're thinking.
It's right.
The big horse in the sky.
I see it.
It's so close.
Oh, it's at the big.
Oh my god.
I don't even... I was like, how could it get worse?
And by golly, by golly, they found a way.
Like, what do I...
What do I do?
Okay, ass.
What?
Yes.
No?
What?
Okay.
I got two?
Two right and above.
What the fuck do I do with this guy?
The fuck is that?
Oh my god, he's right there.
It's almost perfect.
My god.
I guess?
I see another one.
Looks like this mat.
Which one?
This one is way off?
Oh yeah, no, this one is way off.
I don't know.
I don't.
Okay.
I don't know how to fix this horse.
He's apparently way off.
I don't.
Don't know how to fix you.
Oh, I fixed him.
I...
I fixed him.
Sorcerer, thank you.
But in the super chat, thank you.
What is 800 contacts?
They can't have my friend.
I have a special lives.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
How do they keep getting worse?
What does this do?
Oh, okay, it's portal.
Oh, it's a duplicator.
Oh, my God.
Now he has two heads.
Okay.
What?
Oh, he has another leg.
Don't worry.
I'll give you another leg.
Now, now we're cloning.
Okay.
Oh, what the fuck?
What?
What am I...
Guys, what is it called?
What's it called when you're breeding an animal and you're
trying to make it like...
We're trying to make them shorter and shorter.
Or like a pug, you know?
Try to fuck up their faces.
Selective breed it!
Now we're selected breeding.
That's right.
We're bringing it back, baby.
We're gonna make a pug horse.
We're gonna make a weenor dog horse.
We're just copy you?
Okay.
That's not how we do it here.
Okay, now I'm confused.
Now I'm confused.
Guys, it's not looking right.
How do we make you shorter?
Guys, we need to find some brothers and sister horses to...
We can breed them with each other, guys.
None of them are grown.
That is weird.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, thank you for...
telling me how off they were how so very off this is oh I
figured out
it's like here right
okay we got cut here BAM BAM BAM BAM
BAM BAM BAM
It's literally The same horse I don't know what else they
want from me It's It's the same horse It's the It's the same
horse A little bit Two left and above Okay Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
There we go It was the bottom magnifier It was the bottom
one It was the other one.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Well, now I figured this out.
Oh, come on.
Oh, okay.
Well, I figured it out.
Nothing to worry about.
What the fuck?
I mean, he's right here.
Alright.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, shit.
He's so fast Here we go Got him That's right That's right
You think you can just do that Horace fly That's fucking
right Taught that horse fly a lesson That's making right You
think you just do that?
Oh man Oh no Come on Oh Oh How do
I flip this gal Oh, that's how.
Oh, I mean, I practically did it.
Oh.
There you go.
I mean, it's practically...
Oh, wait.
This guy.
What else do I do?
It's the same horse!
Oh, my.
This is...
Looks like this is a little...
Which one?
There's no way it's that one.
Oh my god, which one?
Which one could it be?
Well, obviously, it's more...
His ass is more out.
Oh my god, I can't tell.
I can't...
I don't know.
It's...
I...
Alright, alright.
Where's the other one?
Oh my god, which one?
Oh my god.
I can't tell.
I can't tell anymore.
Where does this go?
Where do you go?
Where's your happy place?
Okay, it's here.
Okay, this is your happy place now.
And then this is also your happy place.
Oh my god.
Oh my, and then, oh my god, okay.
Oh, these are just, I, oh, I, oh, I don't know about these
guys anymore.
Okay, we're gonna make this work.
Um...
okay all right
which is this one I would like to be to be more specific
okay
I guess
oh this is fucking with me right now this is fucking with me
oh my god I don't know I'm oh my god I'm getting fucked up
looking at this.
Oh, okay, there we go.
I knew it.
I'm back.
That's fine.
What?
Okay.
Well, obviously, it's these legs.
Why, what?
Okay.
I I guess
There we go Okay that was easier This entire game was like
What What's going on What the fuck is going Oh my god okay
Alright Okay oh my god we're Oh okay Oh no I don't know what
to do with this one I don't know I'll find mine from the
promised land how far am I I'm just there I'm right there
I'm freaking right there
what what is this what is this what
am I looking at I don't even know what I'm looking at
anymore even down okay this obviously goes here
okay we
have to figure this out oh we gotta cut it right here
what what
okay I'm cooking right now I'm cooking oh
my It's right here.
Wait, wait.
It's right here.
And
then...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I got it.
Get the other paw.
Oh my god.
I don't understand it.
I actually...
Okay.
There we go.
This might be the issue here.
This is where I don't know what to do.
I got one out of five.
Maybe like here.
Okay, then we gotta...
Oh my god, what am I doing?
What am I doing?
I
don't know!
I don't know!
Okay.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Which is...
Which one are they circling?
Two left and above.
Okay.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute.
I'm cooking right here.
I'm cooking right now.
I just need one more.
I need to see the horse council.
I just...
The horse council must come up.
We're almost there.
Okay, we're maybe not as close as I were.
Okay, I'm still two out of five.
Okay.
That's, that's, is that better?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, how do I, how do I improve this?
Let's try to keep pork cooking.
Oh fuck oh fuck that's not what I want to do Okay It's 2 out
of 5
Oh my god give me another one Little too left a little bit
too above Okay what's this?
Oh fuck we did it We did it Horse Council has spoken.
Oh, thank God.
The horse.
Oh, what the fuck?
What?
I...
Maybe?
How
do I get rid of this, though?
How do I...
Oh...
Oh
Okay, definitely higher up definitely higher up Okay
It's practically it's practically it There's nothing I can
do to improve this
There's no way I literally it's perfect It's literally the
horse centipede I made the horse centipede Okay there we go
We're spectacular Okay The final level
Oh my Oh my god.
What kind of horse is that?
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's so far up.
Where will this go?
Oh my god.
We go up.
We're climbing the horse down.
When Wadoki from 10 years ago saved, she looked at the
future and saw you doing this.
I even thank you for the super chat that you think.
Oh, I'm climbing the horse tower, everyone.
I'm climbing it.
Okay.
Here I go.
I'm climbing the horse, the tower, and neighbor, I'm
climbing it to the beach.
Everything I learned
It has led me to this exact moment in life
I understand now I understand the reviews
Guys I understand the reviews I understand the horse The
reviews.
Oh my god, this is what they have.
They gave biblically accurate horse.
I'm struggling right now to finishing this biblically
accurate horse.
Woo!
Where does this horse start?
I don't understand the heart.
No!
The heart needs to spand the horse down.
Okay, here we go.
No, what do I do?
Oh, no.
They just abandoned a horse council.
I don't know what else to do.
It's literally the same horse.
Oh, my God.
What else can I do?
What else can I do to these horses?
It's the same horse.
Oh my god, it's practically the same horse.
I'll never be able to climb the horse of Abel.
Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
Klam!
Oh my god!
Oh my
god!
Keep climbing!
What?
Now that's a biblically accurate.
I did it!
The power of Naples!
Be not a friend.
I did it.
These horses are getting kind of hungry.
I beat the horse, God.
I magnified the horse tower of Babel.
I like to thank all the horses out there.
And that is especially that one.
That horse, that's a good horse
It's like climbing Mount horse Mount horse wrist We did it
Oh and that was a big horse You beat the council toky well
done What a game I feel like I just went, I experienced
enlightenment right there.
That game knew what it was about.
I did it, guys.
I made it.
Horse.
10 out of 10.
I understand now.
I understand the reviews.
I get it.
Horse out of 10.
Definitely horse of the year.
Tom, thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you.
Every life decision I made led me to this game.
This was the game that changed my life.
Golden Helm, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know, not game of the game of the decade.
Is it done, Nate?
This is an ascension of high.
pastures.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Cyber.
Thank you.
Doki from 10 years ago would be so proud of me.
She would be like, I can't believe I grew up to be just like
her.
Oh my, every decision I made in my life has led me to this
very moment in my time, in my life.
the strong contender for horse of the horse yeah yeah gta 6
was that's why gta 6 got delayed guys they heard horse
magnifier the full horse was releasing this week and they're
like we're gonna push that game we gotta push that we cannot
compete against horse magnifier the full horse it like it
like made you question everything it made you think about
the meaning of life and just oh my god it's they were so
scared regent thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you game of the century no other game will live to the
expectations of horse magnify the full horse it had plot
twists twists and turns i cried in the middle of it i i felt
enlightenment i saw biblically accurate horse oh my god it
surprises you in every way level is a unique horse.
Zodner, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And just like that, the experience of Didi Das was
forgotten.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And honestly, any, every had every genre possible.
Puzzles, horses, jump scare, horror, adventure, drama,
action.
at all.
Magpie, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I don't want to oversell.
I'm not going to oversell or anything, but it changes you
forever.
You're a different person after you're done with this game.
How would you... Yeah, how would I even play any game after
that masterpiece?
Nothing will compare to this.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Well, we have another stream today.
manager made the waiting room i was like can you make this
while i streamed this game because i woke up i was like i
didn't take a shower i can't make another waiting room so i
think yeah i think yeah he did so anyway we i don't know how
this next game later tonight is gonna live up to horse
magnifier but we do have another game later tonight uh we're
gonna play animal hospital which is apparently a really um
it's a roblox team that has blown up because it does not
really look Roblox game.
It's basically like a paper, please, but you're in the
hospital.
Anyway, yeah, it's all downhill from here now.
I don't think any game will live up to the expectations that
Horse Magnifier has given me.
But I'm going to call it here.
I'm going to rest a little bit in between games.
Thank you all for coming here for my spiritual ascension.
I feel like all those dragoons have missed out today.
Have missed out on the 1230.
Never look down on the 30 p.m.
slot guys they missed out on a life-changing moment in our
life
anyway guys thank you all for watching I have another stream
later today but I had a great time magnifying horses as
always everybody stay hydrated posture get up and move
around and get that blood flowing instead of for me maybe
step a little longer for the second stream today yeah it was
a once in a lifetime experience you cannot replicate this at
all you had you just had to be there you know you just had
to be there all right guys i'll see you guys later everybody
bye guys bye